MAY YOUR MONSTER.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
>> WASHINGTON DEMOCRAT MELTDOWN
OVER THE WEEKEND.
IT WAS ABOUT AS MUCH FUN AS
WATCHING THE LAST DEMOCRATIC
DEBATE.
YOU ALL KNOW BY NOW THAT SANDERS
ONE.
AND TO WATCH THE REACTION, YOU
WOULD’VE THOUGHT THAT
DONALD TRUMP HAD JUST ONE
REELECTION.
>> DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES REALLY
ARE NOT VETTING BERNIE SANDERS.
>> DEMOCRATS NEED TO SOBER OUT
SO MUCH UP AND TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO DO ABOUT
IT.
>> I BELIEVE THE REAL WINNER WAS
PUT IN.
>> WE ARE LIVING AND A POLITICAL
EQUIVALENT OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> HE SAYS IT’S OVER.
>> THE THRILL IS NOT RUNNING UP
THAT LEG TONIGHT.
AND WHAT DID THEY THINK WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN?
DID THEY REALLY BELIEVE THAT
STOKING RADICALISM ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES AND FUELING THIS
GENERAL MIND-SET -- YOU’VE ALL
FELT IT, SEEN IT, FELT IT.
OF VICTIMIZATION?
DID THEY THINK THAT THAT WAS
GOING TO LEAD TO GOOD OUTCOMES?
THEY REALLY BELIEVE CELEBRATING
A DEEPLY DARK AND CYNICAL VIEW
OF AMERICA AND OUR POP CULTURE
IS GOING TO END WELL?
WHAT ARE THEY THINK WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN WHEN THEY STOOD BY AND
NODDED APPROVINGLY AS OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE WERE PUMMELED WITH A
MESSAGE THAT OUR COUNTRY IS
RACIST, SEXIST, UNSEEN OF OHMIC,
AND JUST PLAIN ROTTEN?
WELL GUESS WHAT?
OVER TIME AND IN THE ABSENCE OF
ACTUAL FACTS.
THE POISON PLANT OF RADICALISM
WILL TAKE ROOT.
>> THE TRUTH IS, I’M SORRY TO
HAVE TO SAY THIS FROM WAY BACK
ON RACIST PRINCIPLES.
WHEN I TALK ABOUT CREATING
AMERICA THAT WORKS FOR ALL
PEOPLE, IT MEANS DOING AWAY WITH
THE SYSTEMATIC, THE SYSTEMIC
RACISM THAT EXISTS FROM
COAST-TO-COAST.
IN SOME WAYS WE ARE NOT.
>> WHY WOULD NEW CITIZENS
UNAWARE OF THE LESS ONGOING
INTOXICATION OF OUR SCHOOLS,
SOMETIMES CHURCHES.
WHY WOULD THEY THINK THAT
SOCIALISM IS ALL THAT BAD?
THE DEMOCRATS COULDN’T EVEN
STAND LET ALONE APPLAUD.
WHEN AT LAST YEAR’S STATE OF THE
UNION SPEECH THE PRESIDENT SAID
THIS.
>> AMERICA WILL NEVER BE A
SOCIALIST COUNTRY.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Laura: WELL, ONE OF THE
DEMOCRATS IN THAT AUDIENCE DID
NOT STAND.
NOW MOST SCHOOLS DON’T TELL
STUDENTS THE TRUTH ABOUT LIFE
UNDER SOCIALISM.
THAT IT ALMOST ALWAYS LEADS TO
LESS FREEDOM TO THE AVERAGE
CITIZEN.
AT THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT
DEMOCRATS HAVE NO ONE TO BLAME
BUT THEMSELVES FOR BERNIE.
AND SO MANY CLAIM THAT OBAMA WAS
SUCH A MODERATE, HE BEARS SOME
OF THE RESPONSIBILITY TO.
>> IF YOU HAVE A BUSINESS, YOU
DIDN’T BUILD THAT.
>> I BELIEVE IN AMERICAN
EXCEPTIONALISM, JUST AS I
SUSPECTED THAT THE BRITS BELIEVE
AND BRITISH EXCEPTIONALISM.
>> Laura: WE WILL ALL AGREE TO
BE EXCEPTIONAL TOGETHER.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT SANDERS, A
DIRTY MILLIONAIRE HIMSELF,
BELIEVES.
>> MAY BE YOUR WORKERS PLAYED
SOME ROLE IN THAT AS WELL.
AND IT IS IMPORTANT THAT THOSE
WORKERS ARE ABLE TO SHARE THE
BENEFITS ALSO.
>> Laura: HE DIDN’T BUILD THAT
THAT.
WITH BIDEN FALTERING, WE KNEW
THAT DEMOCRATS WOULD GO FOR THIS
RADICAL ALTERNATIVE.
THESE NEW REVOLUTIONARIES, WE
ARE ABOUT TO THROW IT IN WITH
BIDEN.
WHY WOULD THEY DO THAT?
GO FOR THE INCREMENTAL STUFF.
THEY WANT FREE STUFF.
AND THEY WANT IT NOW.
AND THEY DON’T WANT TO HEAR
ANYTHING ABOUT COMPROMISE OR HOW
HE WAS WORKING WITH THE
REPUBLICANS.
JUST ABOUT A YEAR AGO, I WAS
ACTUALLY TAKING THEM VARIOUS
SERIOUSLY AS A POLITICAL FORCE.
WHILE OTHERS HAVE LAUGHED AT AOC
AOC, I THINK THEY ARE THE
LEGITIMATE THOUGHT LEADERS OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THE NEW SOCIALIST MAY BE AN
EXPERIENCED, BUT THEY ARE BOLD,
ENERGETIC, AND DETERMINED TO
SHAKE UP THEIR ESTABLISHMENT.
NOW I TAKE THEM AT THEIR WORD.
SORRY TO SAY IT.
BUT SEE, I TOLD YOU SO.
AND BY THE WAY, IT DIDN’T TAKE
LONG FOR PELOSI TO START
CATERING TO THE SQUAD.
THEY PROMISED THEIR CONSTITUENTS
IMPEACHMENT, AND THEY DELIVERED.
AND WHO IS MORE EXCITING AND THE
DEMOCRAT SEEN TODAY?
BUTTIGIEG, MR. PERFECT.
KLOBUCHAR.
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG?
NOT A CHANCE.
SANDERS IS A LOT MORE HONEST
THAN OBAMA AND HIS CROWD.
AND I LOVE HOW THEY PRETEND THAT
BERNIE IS SOMEHOW NOT A LOGICAL
OUTGROWTH OF WHAT CAME BEFORE.
HAVE WE NOT FORGOTTEN WHO
OBAMA’S SPIRITUAL MENTOR WAS?
>> THE GOVERNMENT GIVES THEM THE
DRUGS, BIGGER PRISONS, AND THEN
WANTS US TO SING GOD BLESS
AMERICA?
NO, NO, NO.
NOT GOD BLESS AMERICA.
GOD AT SHAME AMERICA.
IT’S TIME TO ACT.
>> Laura: FOR THE PAST
24 HOURS, MAINLINE DEMOCRATS
DESPERATE TO DERAIL THE BERNIE
EXPRESS HAVE BEEN CIRCULATING
HIS MOST RECENT COMMENTS ABOUT
CUBA.
>> WE ARE VERY OPPOSED TO THE
AUTHORITY AND NURTURE OF CUBA.
IT IS UNFAIR TO SIBLEY SAY
EVERYTHING IS FINE.
WHEN FIDEL CASTRO CAME INTO
OFFICE, HE HAD A MASSIVE
LITERACY PROGRAM.
IS THAT A BAD THING?
>> Laura: WAIT A MINUTE.
WHERE HAVE I HEARD SOMETHING
LIKE THAT BEFORE?
>> CUBA HAS AN EXTRAORDINARY
RESOURCE.
A SYSTEM OF EDUCATION WHICH
VALUES EVERY BOY AND EVERY GIRL.
AND IN RECENT YEARS, THE
GOVERNMENT HAS BEGUN TO OPEN UP
TO THE WORLD.
IT IS OPENED UP MORE SPACE FOR
THAT TALENT TO THRIVE.
>> Laura: SAID TODAY,
SUPPOSEDLY, MORE MODERATE
DEMOCRATS, THEY ALL WANT YOU TO
KNOW THIS BUT THEY ARE A HECK OF
A LOT CLOSER IDEOLOGICALLY TO
SANDERS THAN THEY WANT YOU TO
LET ON.
THEY LOVE CALLING THEMSELVES,
ALL OF THEM GLOBAL CITIZENS.
SINCE THEY BELIEVE AMERICA
REALLY ISN’T ANY BETTER THAN ANY
OTHER COUNTRY.
IT CERTAINLY NOT A CONSTITUTION.
NOT A FLAG, NOT OUR DECLARATION
OF INDEPENDENCE, NOT EVEN OUR
PATRIOTIC MUSIC.
A LOT OF OUR MONUMENTS, TEAR
THOSE DOWN.
HOW CAN A NATION THAT ELECTED
DONALD TRUMP CLAIM TO BE
EXCEPTIONAL AFTER ALL?
THE DEMOCRATS HAD A CHANCE TO
PUT DOWN THE BERNIE REBELLION
YEARS AGO.
FRANKLY, DECADES AGO.
BUT THEY DECIDED TO RIDE THE
SOCIALIST WAVE.
EVEN HILLARY NEVER REALLY
ATTACKED AS HIS IDEAS IS DANGERO
OR WRONG.
THEY HAVE BASICALLY PAID PLAYED
PATTY CAKE WITH HIM.
HE HAS GOTTEN STRONGER, AND MORE
DANGEROUS.
>> IT’S ALIVE!
IT’S ALIVE!
>> Laura: VERY MUCH SO.